اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
حريق في مبنى سكني في غزه يودي بحياه 21
شخصا من عائله واحده والقطار يعلن اضرابا
وحدادا عاما عاقبه الشيعي الجثامين
ومطالبوا برفع الحصار عن القطاع والسماح
بادخال مستلزمات الدفاع المدني
غدا تدعوه الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
روسيا للانسحاب فورا من محطه
ترفض وتقول انها ملك لها ومجلس محافظين
الوكاله الذريه
الاوكرانيين في المحطه لضغوط من روسيا
واعتقاله
في التحقيقات بتسرب الغاز من خط النار في
بحر البلطيق المدعي العام في السويد يؤكد
العثور على اثار المتفجرات على خطوط
الانابيب ويؤكد وجود عمل تخريبيا فادح
ويصف التحقيق بمعقد للغايه وسط موجه
استقالات تويتر تغلق مكاتب الشركه بشكل
فوري ومؤقت لحمل الموظفين على العمل
الاضافي ورواد المنصه يودعونها عبر رسوم
عده بعد مخاوف بشان قدره الموقع على
الاستمرار الى اللقاء